i enjoy his work immensely on espn and i
don't think we've ever met so this is
the first time i
uh have a chance to say hello to uh
kendrick perkins long-time nba player
and now great analyst
on the jump and so much more on espn how
are you doing kendrick
rich how you doing man thanks for having
me on absolutely for
thank you for coming on here kendrick so
let's get into it i saw your tweet last
night about how you were enjoying the
old school nature
of the knicks and the lakers we don't we
don't
usually see type of play like that
anymore in the nba certainly not this
year
let's put it that way right and we're
talking about we're talking about
two teams that are two of the best
defensive teams
in the in the in the nba and when you
look at it they hang their hats on there
that was one of those games where we
enjoyed it right
like you enjoyed every minute of the
competition
guys guarding each other sprinting back
on defense
and look this is this is why we should
all
be applauding the nba for admin in the
play-in tournament
because no way in hell we have seen a
game like this
if you're if the play-in tournament
wasn't in existence right
this lady it was that old school get it
in the trenches
no no easy lay-ups no easy shots
everything was contested
that's how the game is supposed to be
played rich
no i like the what you just said
kendrick because just in the previous
segment
um we went to break
before you know calling you up about how
i'm wondering if the nba would lament
the fact that they do have a play-in
tournament as much as we've been talking
about it and can't wait for it
um that you know you don't want you
won't you
you'll take the lakers and the warriors
in right now right supposed to run the
risk of losing curry or
or lebron from the western conference
playoffs but you're saying that
if the lakers didn't have a reason eight
games over 500
to play a game like that last night
and that the playing tournament would
have been that um we wouldn't have seen
last night's game
essentially yeah exactly and that's and
that goes around the entire nba
like you're looking forward to watching
games tonight that
we probably would have never looked
forward to watching like
the hulks and wizards both of those
teams are playing for
that's the thing that you
and also throughout the whole yeah
thing about the play-in tournament is
that it holds
teams players uh organizations
accountable for the regular season and
not to take it for granted
and look i'm a bit i'm a former believer
of this okay
every action has a reaction so it
started
with the low management in my opinion
god started low managing
guys not really guys not really uh
performing like they should
guys doing things to that nature not
showing up to games where fans pay their
hard earned money
so guess what the nba say okay y'all
want to take the regular season for
granted
that's right let's throw in the play-in
that means every regular season game
means something
if you're trying to accomplish a goal
kendrick perkins of espn
here on the rich eisen show who's your
mvp
so right now my mvp and this and it
changed because
i was originally going with cp3 okay
but phoenix has had a drop off and it's
been fluctuating right
and so with that being said i'm going to
go ahead and say it right now
that you have to give it to your kids
you have to get
jamal murray and the numbers that he's
been up
because of his his performances i would
have to go with big jokers down there
and denver like like greg clapping to
say
the modern day larry birders well
the issue for me on that kendrick is
that we really weren't talking about him
for it uh until jamal murray went down
and you know i know he's played every
game this year and i know his statistics
have been remarkable
and and and the nuggets are still a
championship threat
but i don't know if i if i wouldn't give
it to curry
because if if we're gonna say to jokic
that he's done what he's done
um and and and avoided his team getting
the fork stuck in and
by an injury bug then we should afford
the same thing to curry with klay
thompson
even though that didn't happen during
the season yeah but we could we
we can't give not not at the ac though
we're somebody
like you you can't give a guy the mvp
and look i'm all in for curry i think he
must see tv don't get me wrong he's
having an exceptional year
but we can't reward curry and they blink
that they're being an ac and they
possibly could be a knight see if that's
the case
we could reward russell westbrook
who's your mvp in the east then
my mvp and east is joel and b i mean i
know he missed
you know 19 to 20 games but what he's
been doing for is putting up 30 points
10 rebounds and shoot 50 percent
from the field he has arguably been
the best player in the eastern
conference and that's saying a lot when
you have
over there in the east by the way philly
is sitting at the number one spot
and his note is look every single night
people knows that the ball is going
through joel and b
and they still cannot stop this man he's
a 275 pound version
of a so that's in the east
that's my mvp all right kendrick let's
let's hold on uh
kendrick your your phone goes in and out
we're going to call you right back
back here on the rich side sir how are
you kendrick are you there hey hey fella
sorry about that y'all know i'm living
in
right now i've been living in the hotel
room since the uh
weather the ice storm hit up because it
messed up my home so
sometimes the signal go in and out okay
in this hotel room but i'm right
back i'm right back you sound great well
the thing that that that caused me to
say let's call
let's call kendrick back is you said
embiid is a 275 pound version of and
then you went out so
pick that one that's it yeah it became
elijah one i mean look at his footwork
everything about him i mean the soft
touch the turnarounds
over both shoulders i mean obviously mb
expanded his game he has the euro steps
the in and out
but hey if mckeem was playing in this
game i'm pretty sure he could do a euro
step as well
so that's who i think is the best player
in my eyes
in the eastern conference right now no
one can stop him
which team is under the radar for you
going into the playoffs kendrick perkins
and you couldn't even include the one
seed in the west you know
the sun seemed to be getting more run
than utah
um because we're waiting i guess for for
donovan mitchell to come back and be
healthy um
i'll give you another another option you
know um there
there's a there's a team here in los
angeles that gets under the radar every
single day that they exist
wh where do you what's the most under
the radar team that you got right now
entering the place when i look under
when i talk about
under the radar i talk about i want to
talk about a team that no one is talking
about right
no one and i'm not talking about the
lakers i'm not talking about the club
i'm not talking about that
next order nets or the philly or even
miami
can we talk about the atlanta hawks for
a second do it
let's talk about atlanta hawks right
coach of the
a candidate for coach of the year nate
mcnic meg mcmillan has done a great job
trey young has been flying under the
radar i don't know how because he's been
putting up monster numbers scoring wise
and dropping assists and then you look
at john collins
who should be a candidate right under
julius randle for most improved
clint capela has arguably been the beat
best defensive center probably right
after rudy gilbert
as far as his impact on the game they
have
shooting in bandanovich they have been
scoring and galinary and lou will
and it's just like they have the makeup
and they're winning games and they're
steady flying under the radar
and everyone is taking this team for
granted everyone is saying oh
well we can't wait to get the hawks in
the first round match up like
the hawks are no pushover they're there
in the middle of the pack of the eastern
conference for a reason
so uh kendrick perkins here on the rich
eisen show now that you're part of the
paparazzi have you pissed off anybody
that you know or consider a friend
in the league based on what you've said
because you you you pull no punches
kendrick oh yeah i piss them off all the
time but you know we do but see
let me let me tell y'all something okay
yes let me
address this situation please the same
kendrick perkins that you hear
talking right now that you may hear
saying something on television about
someone
is the same kendrick perkins they knew
that i would say the same thing in the
locker room
like so guys know that the things that
the perk that they see now
is the same perk that they saw for years
especially guys
that i shared the floor with right that
i played on the same team with so
all those guys know stuff they i get
text messages and be like
perky crazy for that statement then
we'll call each other we'll argue for a
minute then we'll hang up but we're
still friends
but you know the thing that i love is
that
all the guys that i play with all the
guys that i call my brothers that are
still in the nba
even kevin durant right that's still my
brother me and kd still
talk and they all know
that i have a job to do right and they
know i'm not going to be
fives i'm gonna call it like i said if
they play bad i'ma say it but i'm be the
first to give them their flowers as well
so
we have that understanding but you do
get texts of people
saying what and then you have a
conversation you you you hash it out
like that has happened
yeah they text me and then i'll call
them they text me and then i call them i
don't call them pissed off i call them
trying to
laugh it off a little bit
is that the flowers as well that's the
flowers
i mean you know and look they get
understanding from where i'm coming from
and we just talk about it you know i'd
rather not say but i get text messages
in there but you and durant
you're you're good everybody's good
you're good with everybody going to the
playoffs or
yeah i'm good i'm good they know they
know hey man look
like i tell them i'm the same perk y'all
been knowing
i'm just now i'm just on the other side
i'm in the media and y'all know i'm
watching the game
i may i may i may be wrong 20 percent of
the time but i'm right 80 percent of the
time
is that better than your free throw
shooting what percentage was that were
you eighty percent from the left
in my free throw shoot my free throws by
six percent
oh man look i know we just met uh
kendrick but how do i get invited to
paul pierce's shabbat dinner how do i do
that
you don't want to do that we don't want
to do that we don't want to do that if
we do
if we do get invited we want to make
sure that all
phones are compensated
in the front door
but i gotta make sure i tell my wife
that everything's fine you know unless
she's watching
uh she could be watching it live you
never know you know
oh my gosh that was something else man
um uh so uh your your your championship
years
um do you think you could have won more
at the time those championship years
kendrick perkins another one
more than just the 08 what are you what
are you saying on that subject
i do i do i think in 2010
we would have beat the lakers if i
wouldn't have gotten injured just
remember
right when when healthy
our starting five never lost the playoff
series so
you know we had we had one game and we
what we had we had to win one game out
of two
and i figured we was gonna get the job
done if i would have played
just think about we was up 14 points in
game seven
going into the fourth quarter and they
just out rebounded this
uh kg was worn down from banging with
bonham and
and gaza and that's where i would have
took the load off from so i i know
for sure i would have had two rings up
under my
but in my trophy case so do you think
doc what has he brought to philly
kendrick that that that clearly you know
uh he was trying to put together here in
los
angeles um and uh and
and in philadelphia we all know what
their troubles were over the last couple
of years
what what do you think he's brought to
this equation you see
see doctor doctor is great with
personalities
doc is great with chemistry if you want
to be
if you're a guy that want to be bought
in and if you're a guy that want to be
held accountable
so this was a perfect situation you have
two guys
young guys that joel b and ben simmons
that look up to doc and value doc that's
the first step
right and then daca is great at putting
guys in position to be successful
that's why we see joellen b doing what
he do because doc
is is saying no joel you don't have to
just go on the block
if you want to bring it up if you want
to do in and out crossovers however you
want to get into your offensive bag go
ahead and be yourself
ben simmons you don't have to shoot a
jumper if you want to be a facilitator
and lead the league in assisted
three-point shot
then do that be the best version of ben
and when you get a coach that buys in
and appreciate what you do and not try
to
make you into something you not then you
get the results that the philadelphia
76ers are getting right now
just remember tobias harris had his best
year
under doc rivers before philadelphia
with the clippers
he's having another great year right now
the white howard is playing
exceptionally well
and then you add uh uh
you add the defensive coach jaeger from
from uh from memphis that was in memphis
when they was going through those the
grind you remember with tony allen and
all of them they had one of the best
defensive teams in the league
he's over the defense so it's no it's no
secret why
they're great offensively and that's
great defensively
because he has now doc has that tom
thibodeau doc
rivers relationship that he had in
boston it's the chemistry
kendrick i appreciate the time let's do
this more i really appreciate you
calling in like i said i've really
enjoyed watching you
on espn and and your your ability to
dissect something and then and then also
weave in your own personal
experience it's it's uh it's not easy to
do
transitioning from uh from the court or
the field to a microphone or a studio
you do
i really enjoy watching my son my
youngest son is a die hard celtic fan so
i'm seeing a lot of your work
that you do for that as well um and so i
appreciate the time
i appreciate you and i look anytime at
me i'm a huge fan
and i know i talk slow in country at
times but y'all get what i be saying no
i mean i've picked up everything that
you've put down
kendrick perkins everything i i
appreciate it okay the who the espn hoop
streams co-host and also analyst on the
jump and so much more kendrick perkins
here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here